Speaker 1: we have a voicemail number you
can call any time.
We had hundreds and hundreds of voicemails
waiting for us when we got back from our vacation.
Let's listen to one who is pointing out, you
know, David, these live streams are getting
so crazy that it's almost impossible to even
use the chat function.
There's something funny and quaint about this
one.
Take a listen.
Speaker 5: Hey, David, I just wanted to say
I apologize if I'm.
Anyway, as I said, can you make some sort
of statement for your live shows about the
live chat?
Because people just read through and there's
a hundred statements and you can't even read
it, right?
There's no interaction at all like word salad.
Speaker 1: Well well, word salads should be
the motto for YouTube.
Live stream chat.
Yeah.
I mean, I agree.
Speaker 5: Flying at 100 miles an hour.
So there's no conversation.
Like, no, I wish YouTube had like a you know,
you could only make a statement maybe every
five seconds.
Speaker 1: It's called slow mode.
We use it, we have it turned on.
It's actually set to ten seconds, but it's
just they get crazy, I admit it, or something
like that.
Speaker 5: But it doesn't seem like there's
you might as well not even have it turned
off.
Speaker 1: There's something so quaint and
delightful about, you know, during these when
when the stream has a lot of people watching
it, the live chat is almost completely worthless
and unusable and and it's unclear whether
it should even be on.
I completely agree with you.
Yeah.
That's why I don't even look at it.
And maybe you shouldn't either.
But I just love that it's like, welcome to
the Internet, my friend.
Yeah.
That's how it works now.
But we do use slow mode.
We could slow it down even more.
We could set it to thirty seconds.
But sometimes people get frustrated.
We want we want the chat to be available to
people who want it, much like YouTube comments.
But it's also easy to ignore it and them the
live chat and comments respectively if you
just want to focus on the content.
So my view is something for everyone.
Have everything turned on but only use what
you like.
Today's bonus show, I will tell you wacky
anti vax stories from my vacation in Florida.
Some of the things happened in Florida, some
of the things happened in Florida and you'll
know which are which as I explain it to you
on today's bonus show, get instant access
by becoming a member at Join Pakman Dotcom.
We'll hear about what Pat was up to.
It'll be great.
And I'll speak to you back.